large backlog of ships is piling up
outside the Panama Canal as one of the
world's major global trade routes and is
facing its worst drought on record
that's forcing Cuts in the number of
daily crossings from an average of 40
ships to 32 and limiting some of the
loads they carry
the manager of the Canal's waterways say
they're facing unprecedented conditions
as climate change is making the tropics
hotter and dry spells longer
it all started in the last quarter of
2022 in full rainy Seasons when we got
low rainfall followed by a dry season
that started in December and has
continued since for about eight months
and that's because this 80 kilometers
long engineering system of locks and
lakes that connects two oceans is
actually above sea level and doesn't run
on ocean water it relies on these
artificial Lakes whose water levels have
become perilously low and that also
Supply pan City and its million and a
half citizens the canal is estimated to
use almost three times the amount of
water used in a city the size of New
York which means rainfall is key to
replenish and operate the Waterway
some analysts fear the backlog at the
canal could lead to emptier shelves and
higher prices around the world the local
ship Owners Association says it's time
to build new reservoirs and expand land
cargo transit to deal with the new
normal the canal itself it's um
basically a water management company and
they're doing what they have to do and
the best efforts to to deal with the
situation because this is global you
know the El Nino phenomenon is not new
it's going to keep happening uh what
might happen is that it might be longer
during different terms it might be more
severe as we're looking at it now
are monitoring water levels Around the
Clock Canal authorities say they will
maintain current restrictions for at
least 10 more months
coming months will be key because the
dry El Nino season might become stronger
right when we statistically expect a
greater amount of rainfall
but while saving water might keep the
canal operating albeit at a reduced rate
only major changes to its infrastructure
can ensure it will remain viable in the
future
Panama
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera